term velocity occurs when the resultant
force
and therefore the acceleration is zero
right
so in other words it occurs when
it occurs when acceleration's
approaching zero right
um acceleration might equal to zero at
some point and then you hit terminal
velocity but you know it might not
actually get there okay
what matters is that you're approaching
it okay obviously this is the same
because
acceleration and force are just off by
the factor of mass
this is the same as this when when
acceleration's approaching zero
forces also approaching zero okay
in this question and this is not
uncommon they call this terminal
velocity
capital v which is a little bit
confusing because the kettlebell little
v look almost exactly the same so make
your capital v's you know comically
large so you can tell the difference
okay so let's have a look at this
question how would you even
begin not a rhetorical question actually
how should we begin what what would be
the first thing
that goes on the page when you have a
look at this question
any takers
i know it looks simple but i think it
would be helpful
to have a picture right just to get our
heads around the situation
a partner is moving vertically downward
in a medium okay vertically downward
so right away before i know anything
else i'm going to define the direction
i'm going to call downward that's the
direction of motion so i'm going to call
that positive
okay uh the medium exerts a resistance
to the motion which is proportional to
the speed of particle okay that's fine
so here's our particle right and it's
exerting a resistance upwards
okay it's proportional to the speed of
the particle not the square of the speed
of the particle
and to save you a bit of time already
worked out it's going to be including
mass this time okay you can work that
out if you spend some more time on it
but just so that we can go through this
a bit quicker
okay the particles are released
from rest at o so we'll call we'll call
this point up here we'll call that earth
the origin
okay so it's initial conditions type
zero
okay so you've got a displacement of
zero
up there and the initial velocity is
also zero because it's released from
rest
v equals zero like so
um and at time t it's position blah blah
blah and it spins v
okay and i've got a terminal velocity of
capital v
and then they haven't mentioned it but
they've got it sort of in the equation
you've got gravity
going downwards right and that's
constant
cool so then you get asked to show this
weird awkward results
what we're required to prove is this g
x plus v v v
gt okay
so this is a bit weird this equation
looks weird it just seems to be
random okay so but rather than
sort of thinking well i'll just randomly
try things and see where we go what what
is this
what is this i would probably phrase it
like this let me rearrange a little bit
okay you can rearrange this in a variety
of ways but i think this is probably
going to be
most helpful if i move this guy over
here like
so then i divide that's common so
something like
this what have i got here
oh no i shouldn't do that i'll just take
out that v
divide by g so that gives me t minus v
on
gravity okay so i'm just rearranged a
little bit now the reason why i did that
is because now you can see
what i'm working toward is a function of
displacement
in terms of now this is a bit weird time
and velocity
that's where i'm headed that's where i'm
going okay so that's going to define for
me
what kind of algebra and stuff i'm going
to do down here
okay now it's a bit unusual and that's
kind of why i'm picking out this example
it's kind of unusual that you have time
and velocity there
that's going to be significant for us
later on okay but
that's our destination so let's see if
we can make a start
on this question algebraically where
have we started almost every question
in mechanics so far f equals ma
good place to start
okay now off our diagram we know what
the force is equal to
right i'm going to take both of these
into account
one of them is positive and one of them
is negative okay so i'm going to write
up
i've got my mass times acceleration okay
gravity is positive in this case minus m
k
v so far so good
so from here i get an acceleration
equation
an acceleration equation is a good thing
to have it's always a good thing to have
because you can climb up from
acceleration
using your initial conditions up to
something like displacement
or velocity or whatever it is that you
need okay
so i keep asking this we have so many
ways to write acceleration which way
would you like to write it
remember where i have to head
now in some ways you're like huh i could
kind of go
two ways couldn't i you're like i need
to get to t
so maybe i would say dv on dt you could
say that
but then you're like wait i've got to
get to v as well so you might think well
maybe i go
dv on dx okay now
which should you choose it's kind of
funny because you've got two here
eventually we're actually going to do
both
we're going to need both in order to get
an equation which has both of these in
it okay
just for the sake of you have to pick
somewhere to start so i'm going to go
v dv dx
okay i'm going to pause for a second
we've gotten to this point many times
before
see if you can get to a displacement
equation x in terms of v
that's where i'm headed to
can you get that out of that equation
i'll give you a few minutes to give that
a go
right here's what i've got um this
statement here and i'm heading towards
a displacement equation i'm heading
towards the displacement occasion
because that should be my final
my final point okay so i'm trying to
piece the puzzle together
um there's a pesky v hanging over there
on the left hand side i don't want it to
be there so i can integrate properly
so i'm going to divide through that
gives you this
okay now we've seen this problem before
we want to integrate but it's not round
the right way
is it right you can't integrate this
with respect to x you can only integrate
it with respect to v
so i'm going to need this dv on the
denominator so i'll flip it no big deal
okay dx1 dv that's a good thing to have
that dx up there because
when i integrate they'll give me the x
okay and then you flip this over
but then you say hmm because you're like
that's not the which which form is that
what's that supposed to integrate into
okay so i did give you a clue
there's a few different ways to write
this but i think the the least
intellectually strenuous way is to say
well i need this numerator to cancel out
somehow with the denominator because i
can't integrate in its present form at
least not easily
okay so therefore what i'm going to do
is i'm going to rewrite this thing
i'm going to say well i need it like a g
minus kv
so to start with i'm going to need a
factor of minus k up there
right so if i make that numerator minus
kv
to compensate because you can't just
multiply things because it's convenient
to you
uh except with regard to mass i'm going
to divide by minus k as well
right so no net change so far is that
okay and that's getting closer to what i
want
i need a g there so if i have
a g added right i should take a g away
so there you go okay now i
have this bit on the numerator so that
can cancel out and i'll just be left
with this and this will integrate into a
log that's really good
all right so i've got minus 1 over k 1
when i cancel minus g over g minus
kv okay that's equal to dx on dv
now i can integrate okay so
i'll integrate this side and this side
with respect to v so you're just going
to get
x over this side right
and then what does this mass become
minus 1
over k one just integrates into v
what does this become be careful
be careful of chain rule in there right
um
i think you're going to get there's an
extra factor of g
right and then you're going to have to
divide by
what are you going to divide by
k negative k negative k that's in fact
that's going to become a
plus over there is that all right watch
out but you can test this out
if you take this guy g minus kv
plus a constant okay what happens when
you differentiate him well
he'll become minus k minus k chain rule
right over g minus kv the minus will
come out the front
and that k will cancel with that k so
you're good
it works out right you take your initial
conditions which i just rubbed off
you find out what your constant is and
it turns out to be i think
this one over i'm gonna expand this
i think it works out to be what is it g
over k
do you have a k squared versus j over k
g over k
squared log g i think that's right okay
so you've got a plus log here you have a
minus log there you can put them
together they've even got the same
coefficient which is nice okay so i'm
going to slap them both at the front
like so
minus v over k
which looks like a royal mess doesn't it
okay